nos dicen que las cuatro esquinas de un
rectángulo están localizadas en los
puntos 11 16 9 6 y 9 1 gráfica las
esquinas del rectángulo en el plano
coordenada que está debajo y nos dan
estos puntos y los podemos mover con el
ratón o con nuestros dedos dependiendo
de la computadora que estemos usando
así que graphic hemos punto por punto en
las coordenadas que nos piden
el primero es 1 1 y recuerden que
nuestra primera coordenada es la
coordenada x la segunda es nuestra
coordenada y la primera coordenada nos
dice qué tan lejos del origen nos
tenemos que mover hacia la derecha así
que es 1 y la segunda coordenada nos
dice qué tan lejos del origen nos
tenemos que mover hacia arriba así que
también es 1 1 1 el siguiente punto es
16 la coordenada x es 1 así que nos
movemos 1 hacia la derecha desde el
origen y luego la coordenada
6 entonces nos movemos 6 hacia arriba y
fíjense que está en la intersección de
ye cuando es igual a 6
y x es igual a 1
esta es 16 muy bien ahora tenemos 96
si x es igual a 9 la tenemos por aquí
y es igual a 6 así que vamos 6 hacia
arriba fíjense que ahora es igual a 6 y
nos queda un punto por graficar 91
cuando x es igual a 9 que es igual a 1
nos movemos 9 hacia la derecha o hasta
que x sea igual a 9 y luego nos movemos
uno hacia arriba
este es 9,1 y lo hicimos tenemos las
cuatro esquinas de nuestro rectángulo y
luego nos preguntan cuál es la altura
del rectángulo bueno si nos imaginamos
un rectángulo aquí la altura va a ser la
distancia entre este punto y este punto
o entre este punto y este punto y cuál
es la distancia entre estos puntos vamos
a ver los dos puntos tienen la misma
coordenada x y éste está en igual a 6 y
este otro está en ya igual a 1 así que
este es 5 más grande que este entonces
la altura es 5 y podemos contar 12